- We're here at the hot guys judge
other hot guys 'cause we're two hot guys.
- I'm pretty comfortable
with my sexuality.
- I'm like weirdly excited about this.
(lively music)
- Yeah hot. (laughs)
- So hot.
- He actually looks better now
then he did as Uncle Jessie, (mumbles).
- He's like a house husband hot.
- Yeah totally.
- Like a diltf.
- He is a Greek God.
- Hot, I vote hot.
- Hot.
- Without even looking
at the rest of the pile,
hottest in the pile.
(lively music)
- I don't know.
I don't know how hot I think he is.
- I think Fassbender is an absolutely
gorgeous Irish man.
- Hell no. (laughs)
- Looks like a (bleeps)
chemistry teacher or something.
- Yeah.
- I think he could come at me
with like an Alaskan hick accent
and I'd still be like oh your gorgeous.
- Not.
(buzzer sound)
- I got to say yes (bell dings)
on Fassbender, I think
he's a great looking man.
- Alright, yeah.
(lively music)
- No.
- He's not a hot guy.
He's immensely talented.
He's a cool looking guy.
He's distinct.
- Charming, funny.
- He's not hot but I mean,
he's got a great body.
- If he was hot on top of those things...
- If he was hot too.
- I'd be angry.
- Not hot. (buzzer sound)
Consensus, Blake Griffen is not hot.
(lively music)
- Don't even say it dude. (laughs)
Don't even say it.
He's not hot.
- Guy's got swag and guy's got flow
and guy's got vulnerability in his rhymes.
- Look away and then look back at him
like it's the first
time you've seen Drake.
- I seen an average guy.
- Starting from the bottom in Canada
is still above starting
from the bottom everywhere else.
(buzzer sound)
- Drake's hotter than Blake Griffen.
(lively music)
- Yeah.
- JT is so talented, it makes you
a little bit angry.
- Yeah, he's one of these guys
that I'm like, oh God he does have it all.
He must have the tiniest little weenie.
- Forehead, solid forehead, brows?
- Eyebrows.
- Look fleek.
- Like you can't have everything
it takes to be a man and also.
- And also get a gigantic penis.
- You'd outshine a bride (bell dings)
at her own wedding.
(lively music)
- Yes.
- Nope.
You think Radcliffe is hot?
He's a boy.
- Dude if this wasn't the hobbit right?
Daniel Radcliffe was not the Hobbit?
- No, that's Harry Potter.
- Okay but he was probably runner up
for the Hobbit role.
- Daniel Radcliffe's
eyes are (bleeps) dreamy.
I'm going to say it,
they're (bleeps) dreamy.
- I will fight people over this.
Like he's not hot.
- He's the kind of guy,
if he wasn't famous,
that you'd be like,
why do all the girls like him?
- I don't think I would feel safe
in Radcliffe's arms.
- Not hot.
(lively music)
- I feel like this dude could,
could like snuggle me,
he could solve a crime.
- He's got a great jaw.
He's got that kind of great--
- His face is an oval.
- And I feel that if
you did something wrong,
he'd come at you with like a sternness
but like an acceptance.
- He's solid.
I think that's the best way to say it.
- He's solid, he's not hot.
- He's solid.
- I'm on the Idris Elba
express, toot-toot.
(lively music)
- Not hot.
- I'm going to say no.
- I'm going to say yes and you're crazy.
- He's cute but he's not hot.
- You can't look into his eyes
because that's how they get you.
- This guy grew into his hotness.
- He earned it.
- Yeah he earned it.
- He earned it so I'm going to say yes
(bell dings) on the Batch.
(lively music)
- Liam Hemsworth easy hands down.
- Chris.
- Chris Hemsworth.
- He's Thor man.
And he didn't date Miley Cyrus.
- Liam is hotter.
- Casey.
- Ben Affleck.
- Like what is wrong with you?
- God dammit.
- I think Casey is a more nuance hot.
- Ben is down the middle.
- Do you need glasses that you're
not wearing right now?
Like Casey's here, Casey's here,
Ben's up here, Ben's up here.
(lively music)
- My problem is there's a bit
of false provado because he's like,
I started from the bottom now I'm here.
Well you didn't start from the bottom.
You started from Degrassi.
- Right, which in a lot
of TV is the bottom.